um so my name is Gordon Shotwell I'm a
software engineer on the shiny team at
posit
[Music]
well right we just announced that
shining for python is out of alpha it's
available for everyone the API is stable
[Music]
uh shiny for python is
um the python version of our popular R
library for building interactive web
applications mainly focused on data
science web applications it's written
100 in Python there's no R code in the
library I think it sort of adds a lot of
power and flexibility to the python web
application landscape
so shining for python is being
introduced because
um we saw a gap in the python web
application landscape I really felt this
in my own work when I was kind of trying
to transition a lot of shiny4r apps to
Python and there wasn't really anything
that I could find that did all the
things that we needed the framework to
do and so shiny for python lets you kind
of gives you a single framework that can
handle a big range of complexity from
very very simple apps to very very
complicated ones without needing to
learn a new thing or fundamentally
change how you're developing the
application
um so for the most part the popular kind
of python web application Frameworks are
really narrowly focused on a single I
guess I still call it range of
complexity for an application for
example streamlit it's really focused on
that first you know first experience of
of running a web application moving from
a script that you're writing on your
computer to a initial web app but what
you end up what you kind of discover is
you work with it a little bit more is
that the framework gets really really
difficult to use as your application
gets much more complicated which often
causes people to maybe start developing
something in streamlit and then have to
sort of stop and move to another
framework or ask another group of people
at their organization to develop
quote-unquote real web app and shiny
takes a different approach which is that
it gives you a set of tools or a set of
Concepts that can accommodate a big
range of different types of complexity
so it's something that you know you can
teach a new person in an afternoon you
can spin up at 10 tiny shiny app to test
the like statistical concept for
yourself but it can also handle very
very complicated applications which
normally you might need to use
something like a JavaScript framework or
flask or Django to really accomplish so
that's the main thing it adds to the um
to the landscape is this ability to be
sort of simple but also know that you
have that it also give you the tools to
accomplish really really difficult tasks
the main strength of shiny is reactivity
and what that means is that the only
things that re-render in a shiny app are
the things that need to re-render so it
doesn't run the application code top to
bottom it just keeps track of the
relationships between all the different
inputs and outputs in your application
and re-renders the outputs which need to
re-render if an input changes what
reactivity means is that when you're
writing an application you basically
kind of decorate various different
function calls which generate a
relationship between all of those
different function calls so this ends up
as a what's called a computation graph
what can the main virtue of
computational graphs is that you can
minimally re-render them so the
application can do the smallest amount
of work that it needs to do to generate
the right output what makes this very
powerful for shiny is that if you have
for example like a multi-page app with
many different components the only
components that actually like cause your
computer to do anything are the ones
that are visible to the to the user so
this kind of means that you can have
like apps load fast initially and then
you can put sort of expensive
computations in places that people don't
necessarily go to right away to speed up
the overall user experience so
reactivity
um like creates it hits this sweet spot
where it allows you to accommodate
really really complex things but your
code doesn't really need to be that
complicated because most of the work
about the wiring and how how those
relationships are generated between the
different components is really a side
effect of writing the application it's
not something you need to think about
that much especially for a beginner
um Streamlight is a web application
framework that allows you to take an
existing python script and add special
function calls that turn it into uh
interactive web application and the sort
of main like virtue of streamlit is that
it's it's a really natural Next Step
from developing uh python script so the
idea of Entry streamlined is you take
your existing python script and just by
adding some functions to that script it
turns it into a web application so you
don't need to reorganize your code very
much initially to get something that
that does run as a as a useful
interactive web application so that
initial experience is very good the app
looks very nice right out of the right
of the gate and the main thing is that
for a brand new user they're not asked
to learn very much to start with
streamlit and that's kind of I think one
of the main reasons why it's been such a
phenomenally successful company
the main technical difference between
shiny and streamlit is that streamlit
re-renders the whole application code
start to finish every time any input
changes whereas shiny like only re
executes the parts of the application
that need to be executed in order to
display something so this kind of comes
up a lot of times when you maybe have a
plot which is based on a reading in a
big data set if you change like some
option that just affects like how the
plot looks like the color or the scales
by default streamlet we'll just read in
the whole application again it'll start
from the very beginning of the script
and read the whole thing
um so there's various different ways of
um accommodating that on a streamline
application and avoiding that problem of
just reading and everything every all
all the time
um but all of them kind of add a lot of
complexity to the application so
streamlined apps I would say they start
easy and and hard so that as the as the
app grows in complexity the things that
you have to do to get it to work
um become really difficult and it stops
being actually an easy experience shiny
takes a different approach which is that
because it has this sort of reactive
framework
um the uh you have to reorganize your
code a little bit to get it to work
initially so that very very first
experience you know you have to learn a
little bit to get there but the lessons
that you learn at the at the beginning
will carry you all the way through your
applications Journey with life cycle so
there's never a point once you kind of
have a shiny app running where the next
ask the next question becomes this like
Monumental task that requires you you to
refactor your application
so the way that it accomplishes that is
by using by executing things in this
computational in a computation graph
instead of re-rendering everything
whenever anything changes
um so there's a few uh strengths of
shiny for python so one of them is shiny
applications are websites so they're
simple like at the front end it's a
simple HTML site which means that all of
the sort of HTML or JavaScript knowledge
that you or your team can bring to bear
on the problem can be used right away
um similarly if you have an existing
like R app that has some CSS that CSS
should work should be imported it should
be importable without modification to
your shiny for python app streamlit by
contrast you know they the way that they
kind of run styling means that it's much
more difficult to add like truly
customized user experiences on top of it
and it's kind of optimized for making
the initial app look really good and
have some some small changes that you
can make but if you really want to make
a customized sort of look and feel of
your application becomes pretty
difficult
the second main thing is the company is
the relative computational efficiency of
shiny over streamlit so because
streamlit has made the choice to run
everything start to finish you kind of
necessarily are going to have code which
is running which doesn't strictly
speaking need to run in order to display
the correct output for a given set of
inputs shiny bit contrast minimally
re-renders components which means that
you don't really need to think so hard
about how your app is connected to
itself or making sure that only some
that the only the right things are
cached shiny handles all of that for you
so with streamlit in order to build a
kind of complicated app or app that
reads in large data sets you usually
have to kind of manually manage callback
functions or caching and caching
validation which can turn into a bit of
a headache if you want to go to perform
an application
so of course all of these things to some
degree are a matter of taste like what
people find difficult or not but if you
have experienced some of these uh
problems extremely you found that
execution model limiting or you found
caching or callbacks confusing or
fraught with bugs I'd really encourage
you to give shiny a try we're a new
framework in in this world but we think
we do have something really special to
offer and we'd love your feedback on it
so Dash is a older it's like the older
framework in the python ecosystem a web
application framework that's built
around this idea of stateless functions
which means that each callback or each
thing that's serving is creating a graph
or table is independent of all the other
uh pieces and its main goal and it does
I think a remarkably good job at
accomplishing this goal is to build
applications which have which are really
really efficient to deploy so I would
say a lot of the things that Dash asks
you to do as a developer are there so
that the deployment of a Dash app and
the way it's served by you know servers
to the user is is really really
efficient and that's kind of the main
the main thing that it optimizes for the
value of that is that it's easy to scale
apps horizontally by adding a lot of
more servers a lot more processes and
you know because you have these kind of
independent callbacks when you have done
the work to develop a good Dash app
you've gone through that process the app
that you end up with is really really
efficient to serve to users so the kind
of user experience is fast and more most
importantly the process of scaling that
app is really really easy for uh for a
devops person
[Music]
um so stateful versus stateless so
stateful apps are apps that have that
where the server is kind of maintaining
uh some information about the user
session mostly when you're working on a
script on your computer you have some
kind of global variable or information
that is passed that is held in memory on
your computer and passed to a bunch of
different functions so in stateful
applications you have that information
is held in memory by the server and it's
passed to the individual function calls
stateless applications take a different
approach which is that there's no
nothing the server is not maintaining
any kind of state about the user like
each component of the app kind of needs
to go from start to finish to deliver
that particular graph so if you have
three graphs or three different
components being rendered on a website
on the stateless framework they might
each read in a data set and each read in
the same data set in order to generate
that component and the the value of that
is that you can is that multi-threading
becomes really really easy because you
don't need to keep any of those
components in sync you could have one
application one session user session be
served by three or 15 different servers
they can be served by servers in
different countries and it doesn't
really matter the issue with developing
stateless applications is that it's not
how you usually program so if you're
programming on your computer you usually
are dealing with one process on one
laptop one computer and as a result it's
really natural to use variables to store
information in in server State and to
have functions you know read data in in
one place and have it be used in many
places by rendering functions and so
when you're moving from that sort of
stateful way that you've been developing
a project to a stateless dash
application it can be really painful and
you end up needing to do quite a lot of
work to move your your process into that
we're all in a kind of reasonably
efficient way
when you compare shiny to dash the main
thing that shiny has is just a richer
set of server States so shiny is
stateful and what that means is that you
can have you can read data in one place
you can have reactive calculation that
does some work on it and then past that
the result of that reactive calculation
to as many different rendering functions
as you want so it really does a better
job of respecting the kind of do not
repeat yourself principle of computer
programming where you're reading in the
data in one place you're processing it
in another function and passing it to
rendering functions only afterwards with
Dash you kind of are forced if you have
like a application with three graphs you
have a couple of choices that you can
make you can have three functions which
each read and process the data or you
can have one sort of Mega function that
reads in the data and then updates all
three plots and both of them are kind of
a little awkward because you're that's
not usually how you're used to
developing applications usually what you
want to do is have each function do one
thing and do it well and you want to
have each calculation happen in one
place you don't want to have that code
be repeated anywhere in your application
and when you're moving to dash you're
kind of have to pick between a few
options and then none of which are
terribly appealing
so whenever I've developed a web
application usually I need to start
developing it very very quickly like I
have almost no time to get a minimal
thing out the door but it never stays
simple it always gets more complicated
there's another ask there's another
requirement from some user and the
application slowly becomes more
complicated it's used by more people
more people want more things from it so
our design Philosophy for shiny is that
we want shiny to support any of those
asks so even though it's something that
you can start get something up in an
afternoon or a couple of hours you know
that you have all the tools to make it
business critical web application that's
used by many many people and you don't
we don't want you to end up in a place
where there's some task something you
really want this application to do and
the framework just won't let you do it
so we start so that's kind of what we
mean when we say that it strikes a great
balance between Simplicity and
complexity it's it starts simple but
that application can handle
uh can grow to be accomplished really
really complicated problems without
needing to sort of fight the framework
to sum up most of the other most of the
popular python web application
Frameworks are focused on a kind of
narrow band of problem complexity uh
streamlined is focused on your initial
application just right when you start
Dash is focused on applications which
are where deployment efficiency is
really really important there's not
really a single framework that lets you
grow from very very simple problems to
very very complicated ones the killer
feature of shiny is that it does support
that type of of complexity so it's a
simple set of principles to learn about
building your initial shiny app but once
you learn them you don't really need to
change them as your problem gets more
complicated it supports a full range of
CSS and JavaScript customization and
also has an execution model that's
efficient enough to handle data science
web applications which can often be
quite computationally intensive our main
hope is that you all try this framework
let us know what works and what doesn't
show us what you're building with it and
help us develop some of the community
contributions that we really need to
make this a successful project so give
it a try and we can't wait to see what
you build with it foreign
[Music]